how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel
and we also talk about dc as well and
today
is the day dc fandom now i'm recording
this video friday night because it's my
brother's wedding tomorrow on saturday
the same day as dc fandom so
for full coverage of dc fandom head over
to my other channel cosmic culture where
my co-host chris will be doing updates
all day
i'll put it up above and i'll link it
down below but for
marvel news today there have been two
new spider-man films announced
coming to sony and marvel and i'll talk
about everything you need to know about
these two films in this video and we'll
also be talking about what sony's plans
are for their very own spider-verse and
how it will cross over
with the marvel cinematic universe so if
you're new and you love
spider-man be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any spider-man
and mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
doctor strange funko pop all you gotta
do to enter subscribe
like the video and leave a comment below
and picking a winner on monday
so over the past couple of days two new
spider-man films have been announced
these movies will take place inside of
the same universe and both
will involve spider-man and we have
official news about
both of them now one of them is kind of
a secret right now but it's widely
believed to be a
spider woman film revolving around
jessica
drew deadline.com was the first to post
this exclusive in which they said
sony pictures is not only growing its
slate of its universe of marvel
characters but
is building on the female characters at
the center of it
and looks to have landed one of the most
sought-after female directors in
hollywood
sources tell deadline that olivia wilde
has closed a deal to direct and develop
a secret marvel film project revolving
around a female character in the
universe
while it's not confirmed it is expected
that the story will be centered on
spider woman
now their sources ended up being 100
correct because olivia wilde
on twitter did confirm the fact that she
is directing the spider woman film
actor josh gad widely known for playing
the character olaf in frozen
tweeted saying the fact that olivia
wilde is directing a marvel studios film
is enough to get through
one more day in which olivia wilde
replied
it's the least i could do in exchange
for the gift of
olaf confirming the fact that she is
directing the film
now the deadline article goes on to say
that the spider woman character has
actually been the alter ego of several
characters in the spider-man timeline
over the years
including gwen stacy mary jane watson
and
jessica drew and it's unknown which
character the studio is going to go with
however
insider daniel richman along with some
other insiders as well have claimed that
it is going to be
jessica drew now what's really
interesting is that josh gad
somebody who is very close with disney
tweeted that she's going to be directing
a marvel studios film not a sony film
now this could be a mistake but again
josh gad
is very close with disney and he's an
avid comic book movie watcher so perhaps
this wasn't a mistake perhaps he
actually knew
because spider woman in the comics
actually goes on to become a new
avenger and we know that sony and marvel
are actually playing pretty nice with
each other right now
and not to mention kevin feige said that
spider-man is the only character that
could jump between universes
so we know that the spider-woman film is
going to feature spider-man in some way
shape or form and speaking of jumping
between
universes we also have confirmation of
another sony film and that
is craven the hunter and it is confirmed
that spider-man
is going to be in the film the writer of
the film richard wink has said this
i'm just starting it it's an interesting
world a great character
it's going to adhere very closely to the
lore of craven the hunter
and he is going to come face to face
with spider-man
so the writer of the film has confirmed
that craven the hunter is going to come
face to face with
spider-man but he also went on to tell
us a little bit about what we can expect
from the movie
he said it's an interesting world a
great character
it's in the spider-man universe i'm
going to adhere very closely to the lore
of craven the hunter and he's going to
come face to face
with spider-man i think that where we're
all circling
is that this is craven's last hunt and
whether this
is the precursor to that movie whether
it will include it we're talking about
those things
and even the idea that maybe craven
could be like kill bill
basically a two-part movie it's all in
the mix so craven is going to exist
in the sp umc or the sony pictures
universe of marvel characters but as the
writer said he's going to come face to
face with
spider-man so this isn't going to be
like venom spider-man does exist in
venom but they don't ever acknowledge
that fact
and in craven the hunter not only are
they going to acknowledge it but we're
also
going to see spider-man and it's looking
like craven is going to be hunting him
as this film will most likely be
craven's last hunt
so there you have it two new films that
are going to exist
in the spider-man universe and feature
spider-man
one of which could possibly take place
in the mcu and could possibly end up
being
a new avenger so let me know what you
think about this news in the comments
down below are you excited for
spider-woman
and craven the hunter don't forget to
like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
relating to spider-man and the marvel
cinematic universe
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you